West Virginia
second most Trump supporting country
Trump supporting state in the country
it's not a country itself uh and I got
to tell you there's a lot of woke stuff
in West Virginia it's weird it's I
really think it's because the companies
have you know have I mean it's it's
there is a lot of pressure from groups
like BlackRock and and like the Human
Rights Campaign and and all these
non-governmental organizations and and
stuff that are that are trying to get
companies to behave in a certain you
know certain way it's it's like it's as
if the Marxist realized that if you go
into a society via capitalism that'll
work because that's what happened in
China yeah you know China was incredibly
poor until they start until Deng
Xiaoping opened up markets and that made
China you know capable of flourishing